everything about the sport said danger
oh my god as a as a young guy I was
totally excited about that if I even
sneeze I was dead
exciting to say the least to some
climbers the act climbing without the
rope free soloing is reckless and
irresponsible not having a rope any
mistake at all and it's a death fall to
the ground so even easy terrain became
difficult mentally the vast majority of
climbers would never seriously consider
ditching the Rope the Rope clipped in
two successive pieces of removable gear
placed in cracks is the climbers safety
net the climber slips the Rope catches
him or her
for as long as climbers have been using
ropes they've also been making the
decisions to go without them so little
climbers who push their limits they
never get a chance to learn from their
mistakes Matt Maddaloni has been working
on ways to make climbing without the
Rope safe or at least relatively safe I
wanted to push it harder
physically mentally I wanted to get that
grade as difficult as it could be so I
discovered a sport called deep water
soloing where you're climbing without a
rope but this time over water so if you
fell off you had that as your safety net
falling became acceptable Matt decided
to take this fringe niche of the sport
back to solid earth the next test would
be a feat of engineering okay let's try
a Youngblood for the rope oh my god I
don't know it's a long way down
[Music]
god it's like too much dude really Matt
took a page from the circus there is no
instruction booklet on how to set these
things up so all of this creates a
challenge that pushed it into a realm
that we had no idea what we were getting
ourselves into a trapeze man would take
the place of the rope if the net failed
it would be like your rope breaking out
of each successful engineering project
comes the idea for the next creative
endeavor learning is the most exciting
thing about life and as long as we're
learning we're living you know it's
definitely not gum and paper clips and
jumping off a cliff and see if it all
works there there is a method to my
madness for sure
am i fringe do I stand out as one and
only doing the stuff that I do within
the sport no but I'd say for for the
main group of climbers that exists yeah
I'm definitely a bit of an oddball for
sure
[Music]
you